Beautiful. Okay, so I see Doug, Shane Noble, Jahill, Stephanie's iPhone, Kurt, Steven Westover,
Discord users, always Discord user, Frank, Shane, and then me and you. Okay, beautiful.
Let's see, Isaac, sorry, Aaron, would you just keep an eye on the people that join?
Absolutely. Okay, awesome. Okay, so real quick guys, welcome to the call first and foremost. Secondly,
if you guys, there are a few people in here that I recognize that are inside of our program,
which is cool, and I'm going to just mention this really quick because there are a couple.
One of the biggest questions that people have had recently, it seems like for the past six months,
is what is the minimum search volume for a keyword plus city that would indicate that this city,
you can go into the city? What's the bare minimum search volume? That's a very frequently asked
question. Would you not agree with that, Aaron? Definitely. And we've purposely, when we first
started talking about this stuff, when we first started our program back in 2021, I was using,
I had been using SEMrush or SEMrush for years. And so I was like, okay, this is what I use,
whatever. But the problem with that is that that tool is all over the place, right? And
let's just be honest, every single tool is. And so basically what we said and we've been saying,
and I still stand by it, is that whatever tool you want to use, whether it's Google Keyword
Plan or Mangools, SEMrush, blah, blah, blah, blah, whatever you want to use, you need to just find a
baseline for what is a, you know, you take a website, for example, that's ranking.
Let's say I have Bentonville Concrete. I always use that example because I know exactly how many
leads I get every month. It's ranking for GMB. It's ranking for organic for the major seven
keywords, basically. And I know how many leads I get. And then I look at what the tool says.
And based on that, I can set kind of like a baseline. So that's going to be our advice.
That's what I've been saying. So I've been using. And the reason why we haven't said,
hey, this is the tool that says this, et cetera, is because we haven't really wanted to
basically endorse any tool. But anyway, all I'm saying now is that we have been working on
something for like, I think it's been about 15, 16 months where we're pulling data directly from
Google to show that search volume. That's one of the functions it does. It also does like the due
diligence in, what is it, like three seconds, Aaron? Two and a half, baby.
Yeah, it's ridiculous. So I used to spend 30 to 45 minutes on a due diligence. Now you literally
put in the keywords. It's honestly three seconds. So by the way, I'm going to take care of that one
that just tried to join. Oh, sorry. I think I, okay, cool. Okay. Anyway, guys, for those of you
that weren't on my, if you are in digital landlords, you have no idea what I'm talking
about most likely. If you guys are curious about what that is, we are doing the beta test for that.
We've had some really good feedback so far. I've been playing around a lot with the tool.
So DM, just DM me actually privately, because I'll send you the information on that,
because I'm going to send you a recording that we did. But that is the beta. It is a paid beta,
but there's a discount on it. So anyway, just wanted to mention that really quick as we get
into it. And with that said, I think let's get into the call. Happy freaking Monday.
Here's what I want to do in the chat really quick. In the next, let's just say the next six weeks,
okay, the next six weeks. So from mid October to the 1st of December, how, and I want everyone to
respond on this guys. How much revenue top line are you guys going to add to your business? Now,
I'm not talking about your goal, but I'm talking about, I always call this your die goal or your
junkie goal, which is if you don't, you're going to hit this number or like I'm flinging myself off
of a bridge type of thing, which is a little bit much, but I'm just trying to paint the picture
here. Like that is the goal that I'm hitting no matter what, no matter what. How much are you guys
going to add each one of you guys? Yeah, not your goal, but your actual, like I am going to do this.
Kurt's going for 10k. I love that. Who else? Who else in six weeks? You got six weeks to do it.
Who else is going to do 20? Oh, okay. I thought I said 25. I was like, dude,
Jahill's going in dude. He's got the, he's sipping the coffee this morning. 2k. I want everyone to
give me a, he's laughing. I want everyone to give me a 500k. There we go. No big deal.
Everybody tell me, I want to know Shane Noble, 2,500 bucks. That's two deals. Could be one deal.
Steph, Stephen, sorry, 2,500. Doug, 2k. Who we missing? I want to know what Stephanie says. Stephanie,
we've missed a couple people. I think her audio is still connecting. Yeah. Okay. No problem. Shane,
I'm new. Currently saving for digital landlords. Okay. Beautiful. Shane, by the way, shoot me a
message after. Might have something interesting for you because we're a created bunch over here
and it sucks to be sitting there waiting. So shoot me a message after Shane. So guys, 10k,
2k, 25. By the way, Kurt is in China. Is that correct? Am I right on that, Kurt?
That's beautiful. So he's going to sling 10k from China. That's the power of the internet, baby.
Guys, my agency, I don't really spend a ton of time in it personally. I've kind of advised
Francesca, but we're going to do the same thing. We're going to go and add another 10k in the next
six weeks. And I'm going to try something that's going to be slightly different than I've done in
the past. I've had a few different months and little sprints where we've done 10k added revenue
and there's no better feeling. What I would recommend you guys doing is setting a goal
from now until the 1st of December. And if you hit it, you're going to treat yourself to something,
not anything crazy, but just have that goal. Get excited. I know that this time of year,
a lot of people take their foot off the gas. A lot of people are like, I'm prepping for the
holidays. I got Thanksgiving, whatever. And that's exactly why you should have your foot on the gas
because that means that less people are going to be calling these business owners, right?
It means that for me, when I know that no one else is up doing stuff, I'm more motivated than
if I know everyone is. And I promise you that half the people that are doing this right now or more
are going to be taking their foot off the gas and they're going to be saying, oh, it's Christmas.
I'm going to start the 1st of the year. So also if you're thinking, oh my gosh, my business owners,
they're not going to be hungry. Guess what? The hungry business owners are still doing business.
The hungry business owners are still making moves. It's basically going to be this filter for the
people you don't want to work with anyway because we all know those business owners that you call
and they're like, well, I'm not doing anything until like March. That's not someone you want
to work with anyway. So anyway, guys, I truly, in fact, let's do this. Aaron, I want you to
screenshot every answer that we just got. And I want, when we get to the 1st of December,
whoever hits their goal that they put in here, I want you to message me and remind me. And I've
got something for you guys. Okay. And you can hold me to that. You guys can hold me to that. Okay.
All right. Let's do this again, guys. I'm going to talk about five mistakes
that cost me literally, I told Aaron in the title of this to say hundreds of thousands of dollars
because when you say millions, it sounds like you're just using that as like some catch
whatever. It sounds kind of cliche, but I would definitely say millions. Now that I got you guys
on the call, but we wanted to say hundreds of thousands, but I genuinely can trace back
millions of dollars lost off of these five mistakes. Okay. So I'm going to go through
these five mistakes and then any questions you guys have on them, I'm going to expand on them a bit.
And then also we're going to have a little bit of time for Q&A. Okay.
Okay. Let me just shut my door. Kids are still sleeping. Hold on.
Okay. Everyone can still hear me, right? Give me a thumbs up if we can.
Yeah. Beautiful. Okay. Guys, I hope you guys are pumped about digital real estate. I know sometimes
when you get in the game for a while, I see some names I've seen for a long time.
You know, sometimes you get in that you go from honeymoon stage, like some of you guys are new
to this and the honeymoon stage is so exciting. You know, it's new, it's fresh. The idea of you
being able to make money while you're golfing, while you're traveling, while you're doing whatever,
it's exciting and it's fun because it's just the idea and you don't have to do anything. And then
once you get into the actual game, you're like, oh my gosh, this is going to take work. I'm going
to have to do X amount of due diligence before I even find my first city. And it becomes kind of
heavy and you get kind of weighed down in the minutiae. But I just want you guys to know that
I've been weighed down in the minutiae since 2016. And I've had times when I was way more
excited about this. I had times when I was way less excited, but I can honestly tell you that
this should tell you that this business model is what it is. And it's the most
simplest business model on the internet is I genuinely like last night I was laying in bed
and I was thinking about digital real estate. I know it sounds like I'm making that up or it
sounds cheesy, whatever, but I was thinking about adding another $10,000 before December 1st.
I actually want to do that in 30 days, but that's what I was thinking about last night. I've been
doing this for eight freaking years. I've made millions of dollars doing this, but the idea that
I could just go, Aaron, you can control the mute, right? Yeah. Beautiful. The idea that I can just
go and add $10,000. Now let's call that $10,000. Let's say it's six of net, right? Just because of
ads or whatever. And the fact that I can just go add a casual $6,000 to my bottom line per month,
what is that? What's six times 12, Aaron? Give us the details. 72. 72. Okay. It's a little early.
Don't ask me that question. If it's a nine, I got you on the multiplication. But so you guys,
the fact that you can go and add 70, Kurt said he's going to add $10,000 in six weeks. You can
go and add $72,000 to your bottom line just because you decided to. And it's not ongoing,
it's not like one of these businesses like SMMA where it's like, okay, I just got
10 new clients. I have 10 times the work. It's like, no, maybe you got 10 new clients and you
did a lot of work for 60 days and then the work goes completely down and all you have to do is
maintain it. Anyway, I don't know how you can't get excited about this. I'm pumped about it. I'm
going to do another 10K of added revenue to my agency, not obviously to my program, just to my
agency and I'm super pumped about it. So I hope you guys are pumped about it because I'm really
excited about it. Even here, eight years later, coming up on the holidays, I couldn't be more
excited about the holidays because no one else is going to be doing it and I am. Okay. So guys,
five things that have literally cost me hundreds of thousands of dollars. I would definitely say
millions, but let's go through these really, really quick and then we'll get into some Q&A.
Okay. Number one, and these are in no particular order. These are just as I was sitting there and
pondering, I'm like genuinely speaking, if I was having a conversation, me and Aaron were on a
road trip, we're driving to Phoenix and he's like, Hey, what's cost you the most money?
And I was sitting there and actually not just giving him an answer out of my back pocket,
but I was giving him an answer that I truly felt were the things that cost me that money.
These are the things I would say. Okay. Number one is not having my due diligence dialed. Okay.
Now, what I mean by that is not having my formula of what is a good city and niche combination.
Okay. Not having that perfect, not having that dialed that has cost me. I don't even know how
I would calculate how much money that's cost me. Okay. And what happened to me in the beginning,
guys, is I was so excited to get going. I was so excited to get started doing this,
just like many of you are that you want to just take a city, you pick a niche,
you go, you build whatever. And by the way, keep in mind, I was doing this the slow way
because I didn't know there was another way to do this. And for those of you,
if there's anyone on here that doesn't know what I mean by slow way, I'm talking about actually
doing rank and rent, building a website, waiting for six months to rank and then going and selling
it. So I was doing that. And I didn't even know there was an option that you could go and you
could pre-sell it. You could go and get a deal this week and then build it out and know for sure
that you have someone that's willing to pay. Okay. I didn't know any of that. And so keep in mind,
I didn't even have a due diligence process that was dialed in. I wasn't confident in it.
I was taking this advice from a group that was, I believe, a bit antiquated. And I just started
building sites. And the advice that I got, guys, was just keep building sites, build 10, build 20,
just keep building sites. And the justification that these people were giving me was, hey,
if you build 10 sites, even if seven of them don't work and only three of them hit, the numbers still
work. And it's like, okay, that's cool because these things are so cheap to build. But I don't
have six months to wait for each project to see if it's going to work. And I also don't want to pay
for hosting for six months on a website in a niche in a city that I'm never going to do. That's a
waste of time and money. And so guys, for me, I made the mistake of just going too quick. And it's
hard because I'm a big believer of just taking action before you have all the answers. But this
piece of it, guys, the due diligence piece is one you don't want to mess up, okay? I'm all about
going and taking action, starting the podcast before you have the cover art or before you have
the intro, making the cold call before you have the exact script, just taking action. But guys,
for you to commit to a six month project at the bare minimum, based on not knowing exactly what
the due diligence needs to look like, what the metrics, what the formula needs to look like,
that is financial suicide. And I have done it. And I've done it on both sides, right? I've
done it in the right niche, but not had my city dialed and not known exactly what a city looks
like and just being so concerned about population because somebody told me that I should look at
population and thinking, okay, I can only work with cities between $300,000 and $700,000 or
whatever it was. And having the right niche, but not knowing what a city looks like, not knowing
what the competition looks like, not even looking at cost per click or any of those kinds of things
and building, building, building, building in the right niche, but the wrong city. And then on the
flip side, I've done the opposite where I've, you know, I've gone into the wrong city and niche.
And I remember this specific time, guys, we, we had this client in foundation repair. Okay.
And we, I don't even know how we necessarily got into it in the very beginning. I think it
was kind of an accident and we got this deal in this city and it worked. It was like this
miraculous event. It worked. We didn't even know what we were doing. We picked the city,
the niche worked only because we had a good business owner and it was very, very not
competitive and everything just kind of worked. And we falsely assumed that this was a good niche.
Okay. So what did we do? We went, we started just hitting this niche super hard foundation,
repair, foundation, repair, foundation, repair. This is the niche. This is the niche, not realizing
we were about to get in the ring with some, some actual behemoths, some big freaking players. So
people that were spending big dollars, we're, we're going against companies that were so big,
they had their own internet marketing companies within the company. That was a separate entity
that just serviced their freaking companies. I mean, it was ridiculous and we got our butts
handed to us. We, we built over 50 websites for one, there was one client that was like,
Hey, let's just go hard. We're like, yeah, let's go hard. So we're like, all right,
we'll build 50 websites. We agreed again, another mistake I'm going to get to in a second.
We agreed to a pay per lead deal, which is a huge mistake that we did. And that's actually number two
I'm going to get into. And we got our butts handed to us to the point that I thought there was going
to be like some serious, I just thought it was going to be a bad deal. Luckily, the guy ended
up being cool. We, we didn't, we didn't have any kind of like, you know, guarantees. We were pretty
good on expectations. So it didn't, it wasn't as bad as it thought. We had some really heated
conversations, some really pissed. It was just a bad deal. And this was all because I didn't have
my due diligence dial. Okay. So the next question people will be asking, well, how do I, what's the
right due diligence? How do I pick a city? How do I pick a niche? You got two ways. Okay. What I did
is I spent, you know, it took me a good solid four years of trial and error. Now the crazy part is,
is I actually have spent about $23,000 on programs. And, and I, this is by the year of 2020.
Okay. I spent $23,000 on programs. That's just rank and rent programs. And I still didn't have
the due diligence process dialed in because all the ones that I bought, those people were not in
the game. They were not, you know, like, for example, we just barely gave her a proposal.
My agency, Evergreen, on Thursday morning, was it Thursday morning or Friday morning?
It was Thursday morning. Thursday morning, we just gave her a proposal. It's, we gave an option
proposal. It was for 7,500 or $10,000 per month. Okay. 75. So either option is going to be a
fat chunk added. By the way, I'm not thinking, if you guys think that I'm like sandbagging this,
that's not even what I'm thinking about in terms of this extra 10K. That deal to me is dead because
they didn't do it on the call. It was an interesting deal because we had to talk to the marketing
director who doesn't actually have the power to get on the call, to make the decision, but you're
not going to get the owner on that call. So it was kind of one of those weird, bigger companies,
but that I'm, that deal's dead to me. So when I say $10,000 additional by December 1st,
I'm not even talking about that, but guys, we just did a proposal for 7,500 or $10,000,
like four days ago. That's how much I'm in this game, right? I'm doing this every day. I'm looking
at new niches. I'm talking, I'm voice noting Francesca constantly all day. What about this?
What about this? And so to keep in mind that I was working with people and I was in programs and
groups and none of those people were in the game, right? They did this once or twice or five times.
They made 10,000 bucks. They had a good month and made 20,000 bucks. And then they're like,
I'm going to go make a program. And the training was antiquated. It was never solved in the first
place because they didn't really have a tried and true system. And I was following these advice and
these different due diligence processes. And it got me into a lot of trouble. Okay. So you have
two options. You can do what I did, which is kind of like flail around and spend four years and take
advice from people that haven't done it or try to figure it out on your own, or you can buy time
and you can go and get the due diligence process from somebody that has done it. And I think you
guys know where you can get that. Okay. All right. So number one is not having my due diligence dialed.
I always talk about this. I'll keep talking about this. Getting your city and niche dialed is the
most important, is the single most important step in the process. Yes, getting the credit card is
where it all ends or I guess it's where it begins, but it's where that deal is finalized. But you're
never going to get to that point without picking the right city and niche. And even if you do get
to that point, and even if you do get the deal, that deal is going to eventually die. If you're
in the wrong city in the niche, in the wrong niche, because you're never going to rank your, your,
your leads are going to be expensive. Like it's, this part is so vital and I, I, I can't stress it
enough. Okay. All right. Number two, the number two reason, the number two thing that I, number
two mistake that I made that cost me hundreds of thousands of dollars was doing pay per lead
instead of flat fee. Now I have an entire YouTube video, maybe even two or three YouTube videos on
this, but when I started in my mind, I always inherently knew that doing a commission deal was
a bad idea. Right. And by the way, just so we're on the same page, doing a commission deal, meaning
I'll send you leads. Let's say Aaron's my tree service guy. I'm going to send Aaron leads.
He's going to pay me nothing except for a percentage of the deals that he closes. Okay. And
usually they want to not only do that, but they want to pay you the net percentage. They want to
say, Oh, I'm not even going to pay you on gross. I'm going to pay you on net. Like they want to
have zero skin in the game. And these groups that I was in guys, a lot of people were doing
commission deals and you know, they would make some money and I would see that, but in my mind,
it just didn't make sense. I was like, the business owner has no skin in the game.
Why would the business owner, if I send them leads, why would they be incentivized to even
answer my leads? If they have my lead or they have their lead, they're for sure going to take their
lead because they're going to make the full rip on their lead and not on mine. Right. So why would
they even do it on top of that? Why would they, why would they be honest? Why like what's in it?
What's in it for them to be honest? And then I'm like, even if they are, I'm going to go and check
all this. So I always knew commission was not a good idea, but here's where I made the mistake
is I thought that the best, what's the correct term? The best deal structure was the paper lead
model. And the reason why is because in my mind, I was like, all right, I'm always the person that
will bet on themselves. I'll always be the one that if you give me the option and say, Hey,
I'll give you this guaranteed amount of money, right? Let's say that you're offering me a job
or whatever. And you say, Hey, Nick, I'll either give you this guaranteed amount of money or I'll
give you a commission based on your performance. I'm always going to take the commission based on
performance. I'm always going to take the one that that's betting on myself. And so I took that same
logic into this business. But I, what I didn't realize guys is that a paper lead model is never
going to be based on your performance. You think it is. And on paper, a paper lead model would be
this. Aaron is the tree service owner and Aaron is going to pay me for exactly how many leads I
send him. Sounds amazing, right? Because it sounds like, Hey, if I just go and I get my SEO ranked
or I get my SEO dialed, I get my website ranked for these extra keywords and I can add another,
you know, another five leads per month at a hundred bucks a rip, that's an extra $500.
That's on me. I can make an extra 500 bucks this month, right? It sounds amazing. It sounds like
there's no ceiling. It sounds like the holy grail of holy grails. But what you don't think about guys
is that these business owners have limits. These business owners don't all think big. These
business owners, when you hit a certain number of leads, they start to freak out. When their bill
starts to get to a certain amount of money, they start to freak out. They don't have the ability
to expand that quickly. They don't have the mind to think that big. And so what ends up happening
is you end up getting to this threshold that you don't even know about. And there will be a month
that happens. And, you know, I mean, here's the exact what happened to me is I got, I had this deal
and we were doing a hundred dollars per lead. Okay. Business owner was cool. We had this really good
arrangement. He was good at closing. And he was, you know, we started and it was like roughly
around a thousand bucks, getting about 10 leads per month. And he was cool. And we were doing that
and we're doing that and we're doing that. And then all of a sudden my SEO, like one month,
it just kind of clicked. I wasn't running ads. I wasn't doing any of that, but everything just
kind of worked. It was either that or the weather or something happened. But my leads like tripled
in a month. And that invoice that I send him every single month for a thousand bucks, I sent him an
invoice. It was like three grand. And not only did he not pay it, but he went through and he wanted
to know the name, you know, he wanted to double check. Was each lead, you know, were they actually
somebody that he could service? Was it exactly in his service area? Did they answer the phone
on the first try? Did they go, like when they went to the house, were they, all these things that I
couldn't control, right? To the point where he was trying to get me to take leads, billable leads
off of this invoice because he would tell them, hey, I'm backed out, you know, two months on work
and they, he would lose, they wouldn't even want an estimate. And then he would say, well, that's
not, I don't want that lead. I'm like, bro, that's your business. You need to hire more people. You
need to be more efficient. That's not me. And, you know, we kind of came to a middle ground,
but it just, I tarnished the relationship. So what you don't realize about paper lead guys,
is there is a threshold for all business owners. And when they hit it,
you may not even know just, just for the record. Hold on one second. Okay. You may not even know,
but you will, at the end of the month, they will let you know. And it's, it's just a pain.
Not only that guys, you have to calculate the, you know, okay, how much is it per lead
and how many leads did we send? Go ahead and get 10, 15 clients guys. And you're,
you literally have to hire, I had to hire somebody to calculate those. And then they're a human and
then they're making mistakes. So then I went and I had a software guy build me a software from the
ground up that every lead, it would scrape the email. It would dump it into a glorified
Google sheet. Then it would calculate the cost per lead. And then it would link with QuickBooks
and it would send them an invoice. Dude, it was such a pain. And that was with software. Okay.
On top of that guys, how do you define a lead? What if it's a good lead, but the business owner
doesn't answer? Whose fault is that? Is that your fault? Is that their fault? What if it's somebody
that calls in, they're interested today, but then they cancel the appointment before the appointment?
Who pays for that? You or them? And there's all these variables. And so what I didn't realize
is all these variables. I also didn't realize that when people didn't close jobs, they would blame me.
Okay. And I had one guy, I mean, I've got stories for days, but I have one guy in a North, the
Northwest corner of the, of the U S I think it was in Seattle or it was either Seattle or Portland.
And this guy, he owed us like 10, 15,000 bucks. And we kept hounding them, hounding them, hounding
them. This is for, you know, 150 leads roughly. And which is another mistake that I made of not
collecting quicker, quick enough. But basically they called us one day, they had their mother-in-law
or something call us. I was like, Hey, the situation happened. The partner got arrested for this.
We're closing down the business and filing bankrupts. And sure enough, they did. We took
them to, you know, we sent them to collections and everything. We got the notice in the mail
that said they, you know, they went bankrupt. These are all things that happen because of
paper lead. So that said, guys, the Holy grail of Holy grails, the only way you should be doing
business is flat V deals. Don't be doing commission deals. Don't be doing paper lead deals. Don't be
doing, you know, a hybrid deal. The only scalable way to do it, predictable way to do it is a flat
V deal. Yes, on some of these deals, you're going to take a little bit less money, but you know what?
You can get the money. You can charge per week, charge per month, set it and forget it,
set expectations. Hey, Mr. Business Owner, some months are going to be better. Some months are
going to be worse. This is the amount. If we can double or triple what you spend as your ROI or as
the money that's coming back in, you have a great ROI. We'll keep working together. The only way I
was able to scale is when I switched to flat V deals. So do not make the mistake of doing paper
lead. And some of you guys might even be on this call right now going, well, I've got a deal. It's
paper lead. That's great. You have one deal. Okay. Go and scale that thing. Go get 30 clients with
the paper lead deal. And you go ahead and let me know how that goes. Cause I've tried it and it's,
it's, it's, it's bad. Okay. It's really bad. Okay. That's number two. Number one, not having my due
diligence style. Number two, not, sorry, doing paper lead instead of flat feet. Number three,
was obsessing over obscure niches instead of just sticking with the boring ones.
I heard this phrase so many times I could just go blue in the face saying it, but the riches are in
the niches. The riches are in the niches. The riches are in the niches. And of course, from the
people that weren't actually doing the model, they were just selling the program. They were just
selling the tools. They were just selling the hosting, all this different stuff. And the more
that I built the blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Like, of course you're telling me the riches are
in the niches because you want me to go build a website in a hundred different niches because
a hundred, a hundred hosting plans is great money for you. Okay. I don't make my money selling
hosting. I don't sell a white labeled platform. I don't sell done for you services, that kind of
stuff. So it benefits me nothing for you guys to go and build a bunch of websites. If anything,
it hurts me because then you guys are going to get discouraged and want to get out of the model.
Okay. So guys do not think that you can't make money in boring niches. Yes, there is money in
there. There's riches in niches for sure. There's riches in obscure niches, but it's not the only
way to make money. Okay. And the more predictable way to make money is to make money in the boring
niches first. And then you can start to, and I would, I would kind of like liken this to just
business in general, right? Let's say I want to start a business and I want to get rich,
which everybody does. I can have two strains of thought, right? I get two schools of thought.
Number one is I can do, there's riches in niches and I can sit there for 10 years trying to find
this business. That's just this, this niche business that no one's ever thought of. You know,
for example, one of my buddies, he, I don't know, maybe they're going to kill it, but he's like,
he hit me up one day and I'm like, what are you up to? He's like, dude, we've got this thing,
we're pitching on Shark Tank. I'm like, sick, dude. What is it? And this is one of those like,
always starting a new business kind of guy. He's like, it's a fan that you attach the top of a
porta potty. And I was like, cool, bro. Like, and again, this probably is a need, whatever,
but you got to know the guy to realize it's like, he's, he's spent now, he's, he's older than me.
He's probably spent 15 years now trying to think of the, the obscure niche, the obscure business
that's going to make him millions of dollars. And me, I went and I said, okay, what's a business
model that's tried and true? Rank and rent. Sounds good. Somebody else figured out, let me buy their
program. Boom, boom, boom. Yeah, I had to figure some stuff out, but that's a tried and true
business model. I did it. It didn't start off crazy, but I've now made millions and millions
of dollars. And now I have the confidence and I've looked at other opportunities. I see other
opportunities within this space even to go and I can go and, and now that I have the money coming
in, now that I'm, you know, secure financially, I can go and sit back and take my time and say,
huh, I wonder about that. I wonder about that. So my, my advice to anyone with business and,
and even, and for sure within this business is don't worry about being so obscure. Do the tried
and true until you get to a comfortable spot. Once you get to a spot where your bills are paid,
plus some, plus a lot, now you can sit back and you can start to take some moves that aren't going
to kill you, that aren't going to put you, set you back. Okay. So with this business,
go into the tried and true, go into the fencing, go into the masonry, go into the, the, the spray
foam installation, go into the, go into the stuff that everybody is telling you they're getting deals
in. Okay. That I'm telling you, I'm showing you live examples that I'm getting deals in.
And then once you get your bills paid, once you get out of the rat race, once you get to a certain
level, then you can start to look at, oh, let's try doing the, the yacht rentals or the yacht
charters, whatever, right? Something that's obscure like that. Let's see if this will work
with private jet companies, which is, you know, probably going to be an entirely different type.
Anyway, I sat and I was so obsessed with richer than the riches, richer than the riches. I started
building in every single niche. I spent so much time looking at different ideas. What about this?
What about this? Then guys, I had to go in and not only did I, I didn't know if the niche was
going to work because I'd never heard of anyone doing it, but then I also didn't know if the city
was going to work. So I had two variables that could kill me. So go into the tried and true,
go into the boring, get to your, you know, revenue point where you're comfortable,
and then you can worry about that. So the third thing that, that really cost me a lot of money,
cost me hundreds of thousands of dollars was obsessing over obscure niches. You don't need
to do it. It's, it's, it's not necessary. Okay. Number four, I got two more. I'll go through these
in about five minutes and we'll do some Q and A. Number four is not, this is the fourth thing
that cost me hundreds of thousands of dollars was not taking people's advice that had been there,
done that. And instead taking advice from people who had not been there and done that. Okay. Now
the reason I phrase it like that, which is kind of hard to even follow was I would have loved to
take someone's advice that had been there, done that. I would have loved to take someone's advice
that had made a hundred thousand dollars per month or had made $50,000 per month, or for heaven's
sake that had made $35,000 per month. But the person that I knew that had made the most amount
of money doing this, that the most they had made in a single month was like 20,000, 25,000 bucks.
And they weren't even in the game anymore. So it wasn't even credible. So I couldn't go to that
person and say, Hey, what do you think about this? What do you think about this update? What do you
think about this thing that Google's doing? What do you think about this? I couldn't, you know,
I did. And they were giving me their advice, but the advice was not correct or it wasn't up to date.
Okay. And some of you guys, I'm not pointing fingers and hopefully not all of you guys,
but I know some of you guys are taking advice from anyone and everyone. And that's the problem.
And I see this in the free group and I try to kill it as soon as possible, but I see all the time,
like, Hey, I got this landing page that it converts like crazy. DM me if you want it. First of all,
they're soliciting. I kick them out immediately. Second of all, I want to be like, Hey, before
you're allowed to post something like that, I want to see your Stripe account. I want to see,
you know, how much money you've made. I want to see your contracts. I want to see how long you've
been doing this. I want to see if you actually know what you're talking about. Okay. So guys,
you have to be, there's so much free information out there. There's so many people talking about
this. I know a couple of guys that live in the same city as me. Okay. These guys have never even
done rank and rent. And I know like, dude, they, I know this because they told me. They told me,
they bought a rank and rent program. They're like, yeah, we did use some of the SEO tactics
for our business. They were doing some solar sales. They're like solar bros. And then they
just decided to start a program and they're out there hawking a program for like 5,000 bucks.
And they've never even done it. So the question you guys need to ask every single time you're
going to take advice is, you know, what have you done in this business model exactly like this?
Not, not what have you made selling the course? Not what have you made selling a tool? Not what
have you made on social media? How much have you made doing rank and rent? Okay. That like period.
How much are you making now? Are you still in the game or did you check yourself out? Okay.
I can't stress this enough. It's whenever we use these examples of like the gym, the gym analogy,
like, of course, if you wanted to get, you know, in, in crazy good shape and get a six pack and
look chiseled, you know, you wouldn't go to somebody who doesn't, right? To put it nicely,
you wouldn't go. But, and that's obvious, right? Of course, when you're getting, you know, you're
going to go to somebody to, to manage your money, you wouldn't go to somebody that's completely
broke, right? And those things make sense to us. But for some reason, when it comes to this,
we don't even think about that. I'm not taking advice. There was this, there was this clip I
put on my Instagram. If you guys aren't following me there, I post a lot of rank and rent stuff.
You can follow me. It's at digital drug dealing is the handle. But I put this clip. It was Kanye
and Piers. Piers Morgan, I think is his name. And Kanye is like, Piers, how much money are you worth
or how much money do you make? And Piers is like, well, not as much as you. And Kanye is like,
well, then why should I listen to you? And it was like, he was, it was being an ass, but it was
funny. And it was really true because he's like, it's the truth. And Kanye is like, well, you
should listen to me about money and maybe make more money, right? So whoever you're going to take
advice from, that's your business. Just ask them. And even though I knew that inherently, and by the
way, just because they're making a little bit more than you, doesn't mean you should necessarily
follow what they're doing. Look at where you want to end up and don't take advice from anyone,
except for the people that are there. If you're looking to make at least $100,000 per month,
then you're going to have a very select group of people you're going to take advice from. Because
to get to 25K is a completely different thing than getting to 100K. And you're going to build
your business differently. You're going to scale differently. You're going to do all kinds of
different stuff differently. And in order to get 25K, the same thing that gets you to 25K is not
going to get you to 100K. So look at where you want to go eventually, where you want to end up,
and only take advice from people that are there. Okay? Here's my last thing that cost me. And this
was probably, if I were to give priority to any of them, if I were to say this is the most important
one, this is going to be the most, you guys are going to think I'm just saying this to be catchy,
but this is the advice that I heard. And it changed everything for me. It was at the perfect time.
And it was just great advice. And that is the thing that cost me so much money
was me being too smart. Okay? Me being too smart. Now, let me explain that. That doesn't mean that
I have like a super high IQ and it's like, oh my gosh, I can't believe my parents gave me such good
genes. No, I've never been accused. I've never been accused of being super too smart. Okay?
What I mean by that is being too smart. And I knew that this was working. I knew that something
was working and I was too smart to just do it again. Right? Instead of just being simple
and basic and saying, hey, this worked, let me just do it again and again and again and again.
I got too smart. I thought, well, you know what? Let me try and do, you know, it worked. That worked.
But why, you know, let me do this. Or, you know, I got a deal for $700 per month, my very first
deal. And it was a flat fee deal, actually. The irony is that my very first deal, guys, was a
flat fee deal. It was in the wrong niche. It was in towing. But it was a flat fee deal for 700 bucks
a month. And guess what I did on my next deal? A paperly deal. Right? I had the deal. It was working.
But let me be too smart. And I started getting too smart. Right? I started saying too much. I
started going into too many niches. I started offering too many services. I started thinking,
you know, I was too smart. And then I heard this advice. Somebody said to me,
if you've gotten a deal for $1,000 a month, why haven't you done that 100 times?
And it was such a simple thing that they said. And I was like, yeah, why haven't I? And I have
gotten a deal for $1,000 a month. So why don't I just get rid of everything else and just go get
100 of those? And that was a very great moment for me because I just like, it clicked. I was like,
I'm being too smart. I need to simplify. I need to be more basic. I need to be more simple.
I need to be more simple. John Wooden, baby. John Wooden, every single year,
he talked about the fundamentals. He would talk about just the basic, basic, basic stuff.
And that's because that's what wins basketball games. So in that same realm, a lot of times I
see people get a deal or for those of you that are in my program, there's a couple of you guys
that are in my program, the process is there. The recipe is there. The blueprint is there.
Don't get too smart. I'm not saying that I'm the most genius in the world, but if it works,
then why are we trying to change it? Once you get to your 10K, 15K, 20K,
you want to go and try and flip the model on its head like I did? That's cool. But if you know that
something's working, just do it until you get to a comfortable spot and then you can start worrying
about it. So let me go through this again, guys. Here's the five things that have cost me hundreds
of thousands of dollars, five mistakes. Number one is not having my due diligence dialed in.
Number two is doing paper lead instead of flat fee. Number three is obsessing over obscure
niches instead of just sticking with the boring ones. Number four is listening to the wrong people
and not listening to the people that were at the place I wanted to be. In my defense, I didn't know
anyone at that place. You guys do. You know somebody that's made at least $100,000 per month for
years. So that's a good start. Okay. And if there's somebody that's made more than me,
then go listen to them. Okay. And then number five, guys, is being too smart, not being simple.
There is so much power in being simple. There is so much growth that happens in being simple.
And that's in every area. I'll share this last example. And then if you guys have Q and I want
you guys to start dropping, I'm going to have Aaron go through it. But guys, this is even true.
I kind of went through this period where I simplified everything. I simplified my business.
I'm constantly trying to do that, right? And this happened to me with fitness too. In early 2020,
sorry, early 2022, I decided, you know what, I'm going to go, no, was it 2022? It was 2023,
I'm sorry. I decided, you know, this is going to be the year. I was 31 or 32. I can't remember
what it was. I can't remember, whatever. And I was like, I want to be in the best shape of my life.
I want to be less than 10% body fat. I want to look like this, whatever. And so I went out and
I was like, I'm going to find the person that has the body I want, that's my age, that doesn't do
steroids, you know, all the things. I want to make sure that they were as close to me as possible.
And I'm going to go and pay them. And I found the person. I went, I asked them how much they charge.
I said 20 grand. They don't do this. They said usually, they usually just sell their program,
but they'll do the one-on-one coaching. It's 20 grand. And I paid 20 grand for six Zoom calls.
Okay. Anyway, long story short, the craziest part about that whole process is that it worked
and it worked miraculously. And to this day, I've never been in better shape. And here's what's
crazy. The training regimen that he gave me and the diet plan that he gave me and the entire
schedule of everything that he gave me was so simple that I didn't believe him.
I was working out since I was 18. I'd been working out six days a week doing different muscle groups,
two muscles, one muscle, all kinds of different stuff, then doing cardio on the weekends. And
he's like, dude, you need to lift three times a week. And on top of that, you're only going to
lift five lifts on those three days. And I was like, there's no way I'm going to gain weight.
He's like, okay, well then don't change anything. Follow this nutrition and do this. And I promise
you guys it worked and it blew my freaking mind. It was like, I've had to put in less effort
mentally and honestly physically than I ever have. When I do it, I do it as hard as I can.
But it is very, my plan is so simple. I can text it to you like in this. The amount of workouts I
do is so simple. I can do it with just a basic garage gym. Okay. That's the power and simplicity.
All right, Aaron, do we have any questions? If not, then we don't have to go spending more time.
If Aaron, is he still on? Yes. So we have so far one question and this is coming from
Kirk, Kirk Dahlstrom. And so he actually just joined a few days ago.
Mr. China, Mr. Chinese living in China, which is crazy. Yeah, so cool. I think our first
Chinese resident. Anyway, but he this he's obviously a newbie because this is a pretty
basic question we can go over found a great city, but I'm finding another R&R site in the city,
big volume and low CPC, go for it and move on. So it's the all what I do. Yeah, go ahead and
answer Aaron. You know, these here's what's funny about Aaron, guys. If you ever see Aaron post in
the group, you can I'm going to put my stamp on it that you can just follow his advice. Now, number
one, because he's getting deals, he's got deals. Number two, because he and I talk so much that
when he answers a question, it's exactly how I would answer it. Like, he'll he'll be like,
Hey, let's do this. I'll give him an idea for live. He'll give me a title. It's almost exactly
how we do it. So I already know this answer, Aaron, I'm just gonna have you do it because I
know you're gonna get the exact answer. Yeah, so pretty basic answer. Nick talks about it all the
time. It's a great question. The bottom line is Kurt is that it doesn't matter how many lead
generators are in there. It just always comes down to the numbers, right? And so the more lead
generators that are in there, sure, theoretically, the more competitive it will be. But there could
be a hundred lead generators in there. The main things that we're looking at is the search volume,
the CPC, and then also the and then that's mainly for the ad portion. And then the SEO portion
is when we look at the backlinks of the content in the age of the domain, right? Those are the
main and obviously, we have criteria for that it's in the program, you know, but those are the main
things we look at. So it could be zero could be 100. Don't treat them like they're all local
business. Let me this let me do this really quick. I'm going to show you this, Kurt, I'm going to
just give you a quick example. I think I can share my screen. Okay, yes. Beautiful. You guys
can see my screen, right? Yeah. Okay, this is when my whole my whole world changed on this on this
idea is I was looking at this specific city. I love how people are just joining the thing. It's
like, dog, you're you're you're a day late, a dollar short here. Okay. Okay, so I live in St.
George, Utah. And I was like, you know what, this is when I was trying to simplify whatever.
So I searched this, and I started doing my my due diligence. And I saw this website right here.
Okay, I think this is it. No, that's not it. Which one did I see? I think it's down further.
Where is it? This is hilarious. Okay, it's not even here. That's even better. Okay, so this
would be a better example. So I go and do my research. And I see this website, it's like just
the basic tree service st george.com. Or no St. George tree service.com. And I was like,
you Kurt, I was like, gosh dang, I missed it. It's on my own backyard, and all this stuff. And I
went I and I was so ticked about it, because everything looked good. Except for there was
another lead generator. I was like, dang it, somebody already came here. So I went I did like
the who is I found the name of the person on the website, I looked in my group and sure as sure
enough, it was somebody in my group. So I went to my DMs, and I messaged it was a lady. I said,
hey, oh, before that, guys, I called the website. And I was like, I made sure and sure enough,
they didn't have a client. So number one, Kurt, don't assume they have a client. Most time,
you got to realize people don't know how to sell the lead. Everyone thinks if you get leads,
and you build a website, that's the that's the end all be all that's the beginning.
The actual skill is selling it. So they didn't have a client. So I reached out and I said, hey,
I'm in your group. I live in St. George. I would love to make an offer on your website. And I'd
love to buy it from you. And she gave me like the most snarky, like snubbed response. And
it really just kind of frustrated me and pissed me off. And that's what actually caused me like,
you know, I let's game on. I didn't care if I lose money. I just want to put you out of business
or whatever. I want to put you down of spot. And I went into this space and built this beautiful
little website. I mean, this thing is killing it. Look at this. Look at the picture we chose
for our background. We built this guy right here. And as you can see, I am number one here. I don't
by the way, I don't even have a GMB. And we make 1000 bucks a month have been since 2020. I actually
closed this deal on the hood of a car in a Maverick and a gas station parking lots called Maverick
in 2020 during COVID and made 1000 bucks a month. And that's like from this no GMB. And I
almost didn't go into the city. Okay, so and look, here's the irony. This the company, the website
that I almost scared me off, nowhere to be found. They gave up. Okay, so if you look at it, and it's
the metrics all make sense. Don't be afraid to go into it even if you see another lead generator.
Okay, any other questions there? Yeah, we got a few. So well, yeah, Muneeb says, I mean, we can't
listen. I'll let you respond to this. Can you list a couple of metrics to identify the perfect
city niche combo? I think I might be overthinking it and crossing out some good ones. Yeah.
Yeah, that's, that's a that's a that's not a loaded question. It's just a bit of a complex
question with the time we have. I'm trying to think if made, I would direct you Muneeb,
Nick had done a YouTube show last year in 2023 titled making hay with Dre. And you kind of had
a live dedicated to each of the seven steps in the process. And so I'd look for those first couple.
Yeah, that's a good place to start for sure. Obviously, those are that's like, that's like
the secret. So that's like, that's what we teach, right? But if you want some ideas, and for time
sake, go and look at the go to the YouTube channel, then go to lives and search it under
there. Good call. Keep going. Yeah, for sure. Jaleel says, Where are you? Where are you in your
agency? Where you are in your agency is motivation. Thanks for the advice. Where should someone be
before they strictly focus on consulting? Consulting as in selling a program?
I'm not exactly sure. Maybe it's time about legit consulting. Well, I'll say this. I don't know.
Like consulting and like the the actual sense of like paying me for my advice. I don't do that.
Like I've I will not I've never actually had anyone pay me where I've gotten on a call and
gotten paid. So I just don't believe in trading my time for dollars. So the other option is to
you know, package your information and sell it, which is what I'm doing right now, which is why
I have digital landlords. Here's what I'll tell you. I didn't. Sorry, super quick, Jaleel, just
clarified consulting with the person you have running the agency. So it sounds like outsourcing
to a project manager. Okay, I was about to say if you're talking about doing a program, I made
a million dollars two years in a row, and then I started talking about it. So that'd be a good
spot to like start a program, which by the way, I got no beef with because if you have something
that's different than what I'm offering, go do it. But just make sure you got the pot to piss in.
Or I might wreck your life. I'm just kidding. So for me, I mean, as soon as possible, you want
to remove yourself from the business as soon as possible. I was I couldn't let sales go. I was so
I loved it so much. And it was a high for me that like I just love getting that deal. And honestly,
I was finally able to let go of it when I started digital landlords and I would sell I would bring
people into the program and I was like, Oh, I still get my fix, right. And then eventually,
like I don't even do our sales for that anymore. But the truth is, as soon as possible, I would
make sure you go through and do at least five websites end to end every single piece of the
puzzle before you start outsourcing and then slowly start outsourcing all the pieces that make that
move the needle the least the content, sorry, the things that caught take the most amount of time
that move the needle the least building the website, you know, setting up the on page SEO,
whatever the stuff that's very, very, like just a formula, and then moving all the way up to sales
and sales was is the thing I would get rid of last but you do it as soon as possible, obviously,
then you can go and you can focus on more strategic stuff, you can focus on bigger deals,
like right now, the only time I get involved in a deal is if it's a big deal. And so like,
for example, we did a proposal for 7500 or 10,000 per month was our options, we gave them,
and I got a little bit involved in that deal, because it's like, okay, that's 100 plus $1,000
per year, per year, that actually is gonna, you know, make a little bit of a dent.
Yeah, for sure. I mean, yeah, I mean, I suppose most of us have read Rich Dad Poor Dad and
Kiyosaki talks about until the business can run without you, you still just have a job, right.
And so the goal should be how can the business run without that's at least
my long term trajectory. So Shane says, thanks, guys, as always have to hop have an awesome week.
Thanks, Shane. It's always great to have you. And then last question, Julian says,
what's the best sales book you would advise me to read for R&R and why?
Best sales book I would read would be The Psychology of Selling by Tracy.
Very simple, very basic, but I've read that book, I don't know, three, four times. That's a really
solid book. Don't try to listen to it on audio. You will fall asleep, because the guy has like one
of those like very soothing voices, and it's just like whatever, but that's a really solid book.
I read that book every year when I did sales door to door, and I read it again as a lead generator,
as a digital real estate investor, Aaron. Guys, we're going to end it here. Again,
we're going to end it here. Again, as a reminder, if you guys have not already,
this is I'm going to show you guys. I'm so pumped about this. This is the thing I was
talking about earlier. It's called Rank and Rent Engine, but make sure to hit me up first,
because we're doing a beta before you just go and start paying for it. There's a free thing,
but if you want to get like a discounted thing, this is where I'm running my entire agency.
Send me a message, and I'll send you some information on this. I'm doing my due diligence.
I'm tracking my clients. I'm doing my search volume. Every single piece of it is inside of
that. You can buy your tracking numbers, and I'm finally able to say, hey, this is a tool that I
can endorse. Super pumped about that. Then who was it that was asking about, I think it was Shane.
He already hopped off. Was that Shane Noble? Who hopped off? Shane Noble? Yeah. Okay. There's
another Shane on here that was talking about something about, yeah, Shane Coogan. Shane,
the other Shane, message me. Let's talk. Cool? Awesome. Okay. Awesome, guys. Appreciate you
being on. We'll see you guys in the free group. I might be going live later this week. Until then,
happy hunting. Let's go get some deals. See you guys.